[Music]
[Applause]
but Shania Twain's laid a single
swinging with my eyes closed but I'm
sure she has eyes were wide open when
she saw her first full-length album in
15 years landed at number one on the
Billboard 200 making Shania the first
female country artist to top the chart
in three years now the five-time Grammy
winner is getting ready to embark on a
massive cross-country tour in 2018 but
first she's in the nation's capital to
headline the biggest Canadian sporting
event of the year
Sunday's Grey Cup halftime show in
Ottawa great cup this is not something
you have not done before you've been
outside freezing cold still managed to
do your thing how are you gonna pull off
this one what's the plan well I'm gonna
dress right for it right you know maybe
I won't go out there and it's Cadoo suit
I'll try to be more glamorous than that
you know but yeah you got to be warm
otherwise you know your teeth chattering
and I mean it depends a quality I mean
you never know maybe maybe it'll be a
milder day anyway but I'm prepared I'm
getting ready for a colder day Garth
Brooks has talked about this since
Selena Gomez it came up on the American
Music Awards which is the idea of what
the conditions are not right singing to
a track where fans right now seem to be
really harping on artists they want
perfection all the time and they want it
to be live what are your feelings with
that when you see that sort of criticism
going on well you can't be perfect
live right
[Music]
yeah I've already been through the rock
this country tour and I know that I
wasn't perfect every night and sometimes
I even forget the words but I think it's
just all part of what's going on in the
moment and and our art in in it with you
as well and I don't feel that pressure
so much in a live tour situation I feel
my stamina and giving it equal energy
every night is more important than being
perfect vocally or always remembering
the words perfectly and I just have a
lot of anxiety about getting a word you
did not so much now cuz I use more of
like teleprompters and stuff like that
but before that was even really
available or I didn't even know was
available you know I would forget worse
I would stress about I would lose sleep
over I have nightmares about that you
know but vocally I have also had to come
to a point of acceptance that I'm not
always going to happen the control that
I want over my voice but I'm not gonna
let that get in my way and I'm gonna go
do it anyway and as long as the fans go
home happy and they can live with my
imperfections then I think we're all
good
[Music]
[ __ ] me for romping the last time you
did break up you did Super Bowl right
afterwards
right it seems nerve-wracking to do
these though like Justin Timberlake's
doing it and people are really
anticipating what he's gonna do this
time around is it that nerve-wracking
like is he freaking out right now we
cross paths everyone's mother talked
about this one offs are always naturally
more challenging because you're not in
the groove I tend to overthink when I'm
doing the one on the thing but you know
that's what her SATs are for
[Music]
the Christmas song with Nick Jonas yeah
tell me about this he called me and said
listen I've got a Christmas song that I
just wrote and I'd love you to sing on
it with me yeah first of all I said let
me give it a try send it over and then I
will I'll get on the mic in my hotel
room and I'll just give it a try
and so I set myself up in the bathroom
in the hotel room it's like the only
really contained area in order so I laid
down the vocals and listened back like
that
oh yeah we sound great together
so I sent it back to him and he was very
happy so when you're recording in a
bathroom of a hotel room do people hear
you yeah I probably was goodbye someone
no age keep singing the same line over
and over again would you do a full
Christmas album I want to do a Christmas
elf I'm dying to do one actually I
wanted to do one for a long time and
what do you look forward most about the
holidays I look forward to being with
family I really just love cozying in
with everybody and playing doing all
fashion things I like playing board
games and hot chocolate are you expected
to sing when family's over no oh my
family never puts up they know better
right
[Music]